ก็
สวัสดีค่ะคุณหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียม
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะได้นักเรียนคู่เรียมวันนี้วัน
นี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนพฤษภาคม
ค่ะตีผชอะไรคะที่พ.ศ
แล้วปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ
2000  22 ค่ะอ่ะ
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้
3:00 น
38 นาทีค่ะ
15:00 นแล้วแล้วค่าพี่แต่คู่เรียมกิน
ข้าวกลางวันเรื่องคะกินข้าวกลางวันหรือ
ยังกินข้าวกันวันเรียบร้อยแล้วค่ะผู้หญิง
แต่ว่ากินน้อยมากๆ
เอ้าทำไมอ่ะอ๋อครูเรียมคิดผอมเหรอคะก็เลย
กินนิดหน่อย Diet
คิดของก็ใช่แต่ว่า
มันมีอย่างอื่นค่ะกูอีกที่ทำทานข้าวกับ
อะไรคะอาหารไม่อร่อยอาหารแลไม่อร่อยก็เลย
กินน้อยอาหาร
มีอร่อยมากๆแต่งเอาทำไมน้อย
ฝาก
ท้องแรงค่ะค่ะผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบปวดฟันเลยพูดเลี่ยมปวดฟัน
กี่วันแล้วคะ
ปวดฟันมาประมาณ 5 วันแล้วค่ะพี่
เขาละมาปวดมากๆ
สร้างแต่ว่าคู่เตรียมปวดมากๆใช่เวลานอน
ได้ไหมนอนไม่หลับนอนก็โอโฮปวดฟัน
ตื่นตื่นก็
โอ๊ยปวดหัวโว้ยปวด
เวลากินข้าวก็งูโอ๊ยปวดฟายเอ่อเวลาพูดอัด
วีดีโอพูดภาษาไทยโอยปวดฟันไว้ฮะ
ทรมานมากเลยค่ะ
ไฟล์ค่ะเอ้าแล้วทำด้วยครูเลียมไม่ไปหาหมอ
ปวดฟันหน้าทรมานอยู่ทำไม
ก็คิดว่าช่วงนี้โควิชเยอะมากๆค่ะแล้วเวลา
ไปหา
ฟัน
ก็ต้องอ้าปาก
หือ
ก็เลยแบบเอโอเคหรือเปล่า
ก็เลย
ขอครูเรียนก็แบบเองทรมานไม่ปวดฟันน่ะมัน
ทรมานมากๆกินไม่ได้นอนไม่ได้สมัยมันตึก
อยู่ตึกทรมานอา
ทรมานปวดฟันไปหาหมออ๋อโควิช
ทรมานโคเวตต์ทรพีทรมานดีกว่าโควิชไม่เอา
แล้วก็ทนได้นะคะผู้หญิงเพราะว่าเราเจอ
เรื่องที่ทรมานมาก็ต้องเยอะ
คู่เรียม B เรื่องที่มันทรมานมากกว่าปวด
ฟันอีกเหรอคะมีอาการปวดฟันมันทรมานมากๆ
เรียงกันเล่าให้คนอื่นฟัง
มีได้ค่ะช่วงเช้าตอนเช้านะคะที่เรียนตื่น
นอน
คิดว่าทุกๆวันจะไปวิ่ง
วิ่งอะรอบๆสระน้ำ
อือ
สัตว์น้ำตัวใหญ่ไหมคะใหญ่มากค่ะรอบๆสระ
น้ำเนี่ย
ประมาณ 10 กิโลเมตร He  Who
ปกติเวลาครูเรียมวิ่งรอบสระน้ำ 10
กิโลกรัมใช้เวลากี่ชั่วโมงคะใช้เวลา
ประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมงค่ะ
โอเคน่ะโอเคค่ะผู้หญิงแต่ว่า
เป็นตื่นถึงแล้วสบายมากอากาศเย็นสบายเต็ม
ก็เลยคิดว่าไม่มีนี่ไม่วิ่งแต่จะไปเดิน
เดินๆ
ดูต้นไม้
ไปเดินรอบสนามเหรอคะๆไปเดินรอบสั่งซื้อ
คะโดยใส่รองเท้ารองเท้าแตะ
อ๋อเพราะว่าครูเรียมไม่ได้คิดไปวิ่งคิด
เดินๆคิดไปเดินก็เลยใส่รองเท้าแตะไปเดินๆ
ไปประมาณ 3 กิโลค่ะ Green ค่ะเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นคะเจ็บเท้า
เจ็บโอ๊ยเจ็บเจ็บ
เรากลับบ้านไงเจ็บเท้าก็กลับบ้านเปลี่ยน
รองเท้าคิดว่าโอเคเจ็บนิดหน่อย
[เพลง]
ใช่ก็เลยเดินต่อไปอีก
ค่ะอ่ออีก 2 กิโลเป็น 5 กิโลใช่ไหมคะค่ะ
อีก
5 กิโลเมตรเตะมากๆ
เจ็บ 2 ข้างเลยไหมคะทั้งข้างซ้ายข้างขวา
ใช้ค่ะตอนนี้เจ็บทั้งข้างซ้ายแล้วก็ข้าง
ขวา
นี้
ผู้เรียนทำยังไงอ่ะค่ะ
ก็ต้องเดินค่ะคุณหญิง
กับเดินต่อหรือว่าจะเดินกลับก็ 5
กิโลกรัมเท่ากัน
คือเราก็จะไม่ถามแล้วนะว่าทำไมไม่กลับ
บ้านเค้าให้รู้สึกเป้ทางไหนก็เท่ากับว่าย
น้ำไง
มันสระใหญ่มากค่ะผู้หญิง
น้ำใหญ่มากอาจจะพอละมันมากกว่ารองเท้ากัด
นะคะธ
แต่มันก็ต้องเดินต่อไป
แล้วเป็นยังไง
เดินต่อไปแล้วพระอาทิตย์
สูงขึ้นสูงขึ้นแล้วมันก็ร้อนค่ะผู้หญิง
[เพลง]
อากาศดีนะ
ตอนนั้นไม่ดีแล้วเพราะว่าพาทิศสูงขึ้น
แล้วอากาศร้อนมากอากาศไม่ดีแล้วค่ะ
อากาศก็ร้อนทักก็เจ็บใช่เลี้ยงก็คิดว่า
ร้อนเดี๋ยวจะวิ่งๆแต่ใส่รองเท้าแตะค่ะผู้
หญิง
มีแล้วก็เจ็บเท้าด้วย
ใช่
รองเท้ากัด
ใช่รองเท้ากัดวิ่งเร็วๆก็ไม่ได้
ค่ะ
ต้องค่อยๆเดินหรอกอ่ะ
และทรมานหน้าค่ะ
เข้าใจค่ะเวลารองเท้ากัดแล้วเราต้องเดิน
อะไรทรมาน
[เพลง]
ใส่กรผู้หญิงก็มีเรื่องทรมานนะกูเรียม
เอาเรื่องนี้อยู่ดีๆขึ้นผู้หญิงคือไม่รู้
ว่ามันทรมานไหมอ่ะคือ
ตอนนั้นคิดว่าถ้าจำไม่ผิดนะคะก็คือทำงาน
เสร็จแล้วก็กำลังจะกลับบ้านกลับบ้านก็คือ
แบบสมุดชาติ
ของเก่าเหรอคะเนี่ยไม่ลดไปอีก
สมมุติว่าคุณเรียนเห็นทั้งหมดใช่ไหมถ้า
ผู้หญิงวาดเห็นค่ะอ่ะอันเนี้ยมันเป็นถนน
หาถนนแล้วก็มีอยู่ตรงนี้จะเป็น BTS
ถนนสุขุมวิทเนาะอันนี้ถนนสุขุมวิทนะคะ dts
อันนี้สุขุมวิท
เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยผู้หญิงอยู่อพาร์ทเม้นท์
ข้างในนี้อันนี้คือซอย 30 มีถนนเอกมัยนะ
คะซอย 30 แล้วก็เข้าไปในซอยแล้วก็ต้องตรง
นี้อ่ะอันนี้เนี่ยเป็น Apartment
Apartment ของครูหญิงมั้ยก็คือถ้าลง
บีทีเอสแล้วก็กลับบ้านตรงนี้เนี่ยจะมี
สะพานลอย
แล้วก็หลง
ก็คือเรานั่ง BTS ลงสถานีเอกมัย
แล้วก็เดินเดินๆมาแล้วก็ตรงนี้เนี่ยรอรถ
เมล์รถเมล์มาแล้วก็คิดแล้วก็จอดลงเราก็
เดินเดินๆแล้วก็เดินเดินๆ
คะแล้วก็ Apartment ก็คือมันมีอยู่ 1 วัน
เนี่ยครูหญิงเนี่ยกลับบ้านคือจัดจากสะพาน
ลอยแนะเดินมาถึงอพาร์ทเม้นท์ตรงนี้นะน่า
จะประมาณ
10 นาทีอ่ะ 10 นาทีใช้เวลา 10 นาที
จ่ายค่ะคิดว่าประมาณ 10 นาทีแล้วไม่มี
อยู่ 1 วันน่ะที่แบบทำงานเสร็จแล้วแล้วก็
นั่ง BTS มาแล้วก็แบบกำลังจะตอนนั้น
ประมาณสองทุ่มเกือบ 9:00 นนะคะแล้วแบบพอ
นั่ง BTS เสร็จก็มารอรถเมล์แล้วก็เพราะรถ
เมล์มาเนี่ยถึงตรงสะพานลอยแล้วแบบปวดท้อง
มาก
อยากเข้าห้องน้ำอ่ะไม่ใช่ปวดฉี่นะคะไม่
ใช่ปวดฉี่นะเวลาที่เรากินอาหารกินอาหาร
ใช่มั้ยอะไรนะคะปวดท้องแบบไหนเจ็บ
ปวดท้องแบบใหญ่อยากเข้าห้องน้ำอ่ะอยาก
เข้าห้องน้ำ
ตอนที่นอนรถเมย์ไหม
ไม่ค่ะแต่มันปวดแบบนิดหน่อยไงคือเราก็คิด
ว่ามึงเราอดทนได้
21:00 นรถไม่ติดแล้วใช้เวลานิดหน่อยก็
ถึงบ้านทำไมเราแบบเราก็อดทนอดทนว่าง่าย
แต่แบบคุณเรียมมันไม่รู้มันเรียกว่ามัน
ทรมานไหมอ่ะมันทรมานนั้นแบบเราปวดท้องอ่ะ
แล้วมันเข้าห้องน้ำไม่ได้กับตอนอยู่บนรถ
ในเรารู้สึกว่าแบบเราอดทนได้ชนได้อดทนได้
แต่พอเราลงจากรถเดินพอเราเริ่มเดินเรา
เริ่มขยับเนี่ยท้องเนี่ยมัน
มันไว้โอเคแล้วไงผู้หญิงก็นี่ก็บอกคุยก็
ไปกับครูเอ๋นะคะคุณน้าสองคนกลับบ้านพร้อม
กัน
กูอ่ะมีผู้ใหญ่ขึ้นขอเดินไปก่อนเลยไม่ไหว
แล้ว
ขนลุกแล้วว่าใครนักเรียนว่ามันปวดท้องมาก
ๆอ่ะ
ไม่รู้มันทรมานไหมนะเนี่ยผู้หญิงหรือซื้อ
มันทรมานมากเลยนะเวลาเราปวดท้องแล้วมัน
เข้าห้องน้ำไม่ได้อ่ะกูเรียมวิ่งวิ่งพอจะ
วิ่งมันก็แบบไม่ได้ไม่ได้ถ้าเราวิ่ง
มันจะออกมา
เก็บอะไรไม่ค่อยเดินแบบเงินเดินๆแบบคิด
บ้านเว้น Apartment  Apartment  Apartment
คือทุกวันแล้วรู้สึกว่าแบบเดินประมาณ 10
นาทีก็ถึงอพาร์ทเม้นท์แล้วแต่โชคดีนะคะ
ภายในผู้หญิงอ่ะมีแค่สองชั้นไม่ต้องรอ
ลิฟต์ไม่ต้องรอลิฟต์อ่ะก็ถึงอพาร์ทเม้นท์
ก็วิ่งไม่มีแบบแบบโอ้โหๆๆรีบเดินผู้หญิง
ค้าถ้าเกิดมีเพื่อนครูหญิงผ่านมาเห็นมี
ผู้หญิงมาก
วันจันทร์
ไม่โครเอไม่คุย
คุยก็มีระบบกุญแจเกือบเวลาเที่ยวรีบอ่ะ
กุญแจที่มันเมื่อก่อนมันต้องมีกุญแจแบบ
แบบนี้ต้องเรียกอะไรอ่ะที่เป็นแม่กุญแจกู
กูเลียมคืออพาร์ทเม้นต์ผู้หญิงล็อคแบบดี
แม่กุญแจ
เนี่ยนักเรียน
เออล็อค 2 ชั้นก็คือร้องไห้กุญแจ 1 แล้ว
ก็ไม่ไขกุญแจชั่วรู้สึกแบบเวลาที่เราปวด
ท้องรู้สึกว่า
ทำไมนะคะแต่ว่าโชคดีนะครับพี่เข้าห้องน้ำ
ทันนะคะโอเคไม่มีอะไรแต่แค่รู้สึกแบบมัน
ทรมานมากๆกับเวลาที่เราปวดท้องแล้วเรา
อยากเข้าห้องน้ำอ่ะคือไม่รู้มันทรมานไหม
มันก็ทรมานเนาะจิตนาทีนมัธรู้สึกแบบ
เหมือน
ถ้าถามว่ามากกว่า 10 นาที
คิดว่าเหมือน 10 ชั่วโมงนะคะนักเรียนคือ
แบบอะไรทำไมอ่ะแต่มันเป็นอะไรที่แบบทรมาน
มากแบบเวลาที่เราปวดท้องแล้วเราไม่ได้
เข้าห้องน้ำใช่เรียงเข้าใจผู้หญิงเลย
เพราะว่าที่ครูหญิงเล่ามาทำให้เรียนคิด
ได้ว่าอ๋อเนี่ยก็เคยปวดท้องเข้าห้องน้ำ
เหมือนกัน
ผู้เรียนไป
ยังอยู่บนรถค่ะครูโหร
กูเรียมขับ
รถตัวเองใช่ไหมมีแบบมีเพื่อนๆในรถ
เพื่อนๆในรถแล้วก็มีเรียง
ถามว่าขนนที่เราไปค่ะผู้หญิงมีต้นไม้ต้น
ไม้
เยอะมากๆคิดมี
มีน้ำไหมไม่มี
แล้วครูเรียมปวดท้องปวดท้องอยากเข้าห้อง
น้ำ
ก็เลยรอห้องน้ำห้องน้ำเพื่อนก็ขับรถขับรถ
แล้วมีแบบต้นไม้ต้นไม้แล้วก็คางค่ะผู้
หญิง
ชาวนายาวมากๆ
คนเดียวทำยังไงก็รออยู่ในรถเมล์ก็นั่ง
นิ่งๆนั่งๆคน
ทนมากแล้วก็ผ่านไปประมาณ 10 นาทีผ่านไป
20 นาทีผ่านไปมวยทรมานจังเลย
ว่าพูดไม่ได้นะผู้หญิงผู้เลี้ยงต้องนั่ง
ต้องนั่งนิ่งๆใช่ไหมขยับขยับมากไม่ได้ปวด
ท้อง
ขยับไม่ได้ขยับตัว
สี
ม่วง
พูดได้พูดได้นิดหน่อย
เลี้ยงเป็นยังไงโอเคไหม
เร็วๆขับรถเร็วๆ
วันนั้นเรื่องใส่รองเท้าส้นสูงไปด้วยค่ะ
แต่รองเท้าส้นสูงไป
แล้วพอแบบมันจะมีปั๊มน้ำมัน
มันจะมีปั๊มน้ำมัน
แต่เวลาเราขับรถแล้วเติมน้ำมันใช่ไหมที่
ปั๊มอ่ะแล้วเพื่อนก็เลยแบบขับรถเข้าไปใน
ปั๊มน้ำมัน
อ่ะ
ไม่เอาไม่ใส่รองเท้า
ใส่รองเท้ามีคนสูงไม่ได้
ก็เลยกับซื้อรองเท้าส้นสูงแล้วก็พี่นี่
วิ่งๆ
ไปเข้าห้องไม่ต้องสวยแล้วห้องรักไม่สวย
ทันไหมคะหรือรองเท้าทันหายโชคดีมาก
แต่ก็ทรมานแล้วหญิง
เราปวดท้องแล้วแบบห้องน้ำห้องน้ำอยู่ที่
ไหนแล้วเราไม่ได้เข้าคุยรู้สึกว่ามัน
ทรมานเหมือนกันนะแต่อาจจะไม่ใช่ไม่เท่า
กับปวดฟันปวดฟันเนี่ยรู้สึกว่าทรมานมาก
กว่าอยู่ว่าคุณเรียมที่ไปเดินรอบสระน้ำ
รองเท้ากันคือรองเท้ากัดแล้วเราต้องเดิน
เนี่ยทรมานมากนะคะ
แล้วเราก็คือผู้หญิงเนี่ยเรียกเข้าห้อง
น้ำ
ผู้หญิงรู้สึกว่าทำไม
[เพลง]
ดูแล้วมันไม่มีห้องน้ำอื่นนะเราต้องเข้า
อพาร์ทเม้นของเราเท่านั้นน่ะแล้วการไข
กุญแจมคือแบบสุวรรณเนี่ยเราแชร์เวลาแบบ
ห้าวินาทีใช่ไหมห้าสี่สามสองหนึ่งเสร็จ
เวลาที่เราปวดท้องอ่ะเหอะไม่ได้แล้วจะขาย
กุญแจได้รู้สึกทรมานเหมือนกันใช่
อันนี้แค่แบบทรมานเกี่ยวกับร่างกายเฉยๆ
คุณเขาแบบไม่ได้ไม่ได้รักกันเนี้ยผู้ชาย
กับผู้หญิง
ที่ไม่ได้รักกันแต่ก็มาค่ะกัน
โหอันนี้ก็ทรมานนะ
อยู่บ้านอยู่บ้านด้วยกันเรียนคิดว่ามันคอ
ระมาณกัน
แต่นี่มันไม่ใช่ร่างกายเนาะเป็นใจใช่ไหม
ประมาณที่ฉันได้ออกมาไม่มีความถี่ไม่มี
ความสุขใช่ไหม
ทรมานร่างกายดีกว่าจะกำลังกายให้งานแต่
นักเรียนไม่
เหนื่อยกับนักเรียนไม่ทรมานใจใช่ไหมเวลา
ดูวีดีโอเราอายคิดว่าถ้านักเรียนดูวีดีโอ
แล้วมีความสุขก็ไม่ทรมานใจ
ถ้าเราทำอะไรไม่มีความสุขและเราต้องทำก็
ทรมานใจแต่เราสองคนไม่ทรมานใจนะไม่เท่า
เราทรมาน
ร้านกาย
คู่เรียนเขากำลังทรมานร่างกายอยู่ค่ะปวด
ฟันแต่ไม่ไปหาหมอ
เดี๋ยวคิดไปหาหมอหนูไม่ไปหาหมอไปหาหมอให้
ไปหาไม่รู้ค่ะแต่ว่าที่รู้ตอนนี้คือเวลา
ดีแล้วใช่ไหมคะอะไรคะ
ชายเวลาหมดแล้วน้องนักเรียนเราสองคนก็
ต้องไปก่อนแล้วใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะเดี๋ยวเจอ
ผู้หญิงกับผู้เดียวในช่อง Coffee เห็น
สิเบอร์ไทยในคลิปหน้านะคะ
ใส่ค่ะส่วนไปแล้ว 2 คนก็สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนะสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียม
ว่าบายน